décidément cette période de noël est
fertile en surprises à quel ciel se
vouer un ciel clément un ciel nuageux un
ciel plein de neige un ciel d'où tombent
l'appui on ne sait pas très bien
regarder ces images étonnantes
elles nous viennent de l'ariège elles
ont été tournées
il y a de cela quelques heures des
skieurs torse nu donc nous pouvons en
conclure qu'il fait beau et qu'il fait
chaud sur les pentes neigeuses de
l'ariège mais pourtant entre toulouse et
muret hier soir à 22h30 il y avait
tellement de brouillard qu'un
gigantesque carambolage s'est produit
sur la nationale 125 un kilomètre après
la sortie de muret en direction de
toulouse sur une voie à double
circulation regardez là encore ces
images assez étonnante
au total plusieurs dizaines de véhicules
qui ont été choqués les uns contre les
autres
onze blessés dont sept graves le
conducteur d'une voiture de tourisme
avaient été gênées par le brouillard il
avait freiné provoquant la collision de
neuf collision de neuf véhicules dont
deux camions et puis les autres
automobilistes voulant s'arrêter ont
provoqué eux mêmes un deuxième
embouteillages beau temps d'un côté
brouillard de l'autre décidément les
heures passent et le ciel n'est pas
toujours le même alors regardons ce qui
va se passer cet après-midi le temps
doux et ensoleillé persistera sur la
moitié est de la france
des nuages abondant sur la moitié ouest
quelques pluies seront observées en fin
d'après-midi de la vendée aux pyrénées
et puis demain le temps doux et pluvieux
gagnera la moitié ouest du pays
en matinée puis la moitié est dans
l'après midi
cet épisode pluvieux sera suivie de
vents violents sur le golfe de gascogne
et les côtes de la manche donc vous le
voyez il faut s'attendre à des
alternances de très beaux de très
mauvais nous sommes au mois de décembre
seul est aussi un peu compréhension nous
sommes le 26 décembre lendemain de noël
il
ah vous le savez vous l'avez réaliser
vous-même toute la france le monde
entier à fêter noël en famille devant
les postes de télévision en allant aussi
aux offices célébrés à cette occasion
hier à 7 heures si nous parlions avec
bernard chevalier de le mée 10e du pape
jean paul 2 qui pour la première fois
bénis c'est la foule sur la place saint
pierre où donner sa bénédiction urbi et
orbi vis que c'était le premier noël du
pape polonais dans le même temps et bien
les évêques de france prenait la parole
dans les différents diocèses pour
évoquer cette période de noël évoqué
aussi les préoccupations quotidiennes
des français car l'église est proche
vous le savez de nos préoccupations
quotidiennes
je vous parlais hier du reste de ce
qu'avait dit l'archevêque monseigneur
bernard à longwy à propos du chômage
mais d'autres déclarations ont été
faites par les évêques de france bernard
chevallier
oui je crois le cardinal marty en donne
le sens explications lorsqu'il dit
citant d'évêques sont intervenus c'est
pour marquer la solidarité avec les
chômeurs ou les victimes de la crise et
pour sentir qu'ils ne sont pas isolés et
le cas et l'archevêque de paris
d'ajouter je considère d'ailleurs que
les enfants dès chômeurs sont un peu
comme des orphelins
cela dit les évêques de la région est
bien sûr n'ont pas manqué de vouloir
affirmer leur solidarité avec ce monde
du travail
l'évêque de nancy monseigneur bernard le
soir de noël a eu des paroles très ferme
il ne faut pas se tromper de noël il ne
faut pas croire au père noël car at-il
dit noël marque le début d'une
solidarité durable et at il ajouté il
faut lutter de toutes nos forces pour
que nous trouvions des emplois
monseigneur ménagers l'archevêque de
reims est allé lui aussi passé la nuit
de noël avec des ouvriers
l'archevêque de ces monseigneur dire
ouais et à main est allé un peu plus
loin lorsqu'il souhaite une nouvelle
répartition du travail et lorsqu'il
demande aux soucoupes aux foyers qui ont
un double salaire de supprimer l'un des
salaires pour permettre un jeune adulte
d'avoir du travail
l'archevêque de reims bien sûr l'évêque
d'arras et l'évêque d'agen la semaine
dernière déjà pris position sur les
problèmes de la situation économique et
cela marque je crois le désir de
église de france des évêques bien sûr
mais aussi des mouvements d'action
catholique qui travaille dans ce sens là
de ne pas laisser l'ensemble de tous
ceux qui sont victimes de la crise deux
côtés alors je le disais il ya quelques
instants on a l'impression quand même
que les évêques français deviennent de
plus en plus proche des préoccupations
se rapproche des préoccupations
quotidiennes et d'aider des chômeurs des
ouvriers des fans ils ont défoncé en
général il
mais ça ils ne savaient pas l'exprimer
de façon aussi claire et en trouvant en
faisant des gestes comme ceux qui l'ont
fait ce jour de noël c'est à dire en
allant sur les lieux mêmes où se joue
l'avenir des hommes ils ont voulu
montrer effectivement qu'ils avaient
l'intention d'être beaucoup plus près et
de marquer cette solidarité qui
jusqu'ici
j'allais dire s'affirmait duo des chers
mais sans beaucoup d'effet il faut dire
aussi que ces déclarations ont été
préparés la plupart du temps avec des
chrétiens avec des militants
syndicalistes qui sont engagés qui sont
eux aussi victimes de ce qui se passe et
que lorsque les évêques parle en fait il
ne parle pas tout seul l'un d'eux un
évêque l'évêque d'autun a même cru bon
d'envoyer à ses diocésains une mini
cassette sur laquelle il explique à la
fois le sens de noël et leur demande
disent on veut travailler utilement avec
lui pour vaincre toutes les inégalités
donc voyez on cherche beaucoup
d'initiatives pour coller de plus près à
la vie de tous les jours
alors avant de il y avait de temps en
temps comme ça une déclaration parce que
peut-être pour des raisons géographiques
lévesque était plus proche de 2 c ces
ouvriers de ces chômeurs apparemment là
il ya un consensus général
l'impression que ya presque une ligne de
conduite de l'ensemble des évêques de
france c'est vrai ou pas c'est à dire il
avait déjà eu à lourdes il ya deux
années d ou trois ans une prise de
conscience à ce niveau là je crois que
maintenant les évêques sont proches des
réalités ne vivent plus enfermés dans
leur archevêché au milieu de beaux
meubles de bibliothèques et de beaux
tableaux et il semble que si l'église
veut être véritablement l'église avec
d'autres croyants avec leurs frères
chrétiens avec les protestants et avec
tous les croyants ils essayent de sortir
un petit peu d'un ghetto pour aller
vraiment là où se joue l'avenir de
l'homme merci bernard chevalier pour ces
précisions au lendemain de noël
lendemain de noël qui nous permet
maintenant de regarder d'une façon un
peu plus quotidienne l'actualité jean
pierre pernaut plusieurs centaines de
milliers de personnes défilent ce matin
dans les rues de machhad en iront
manifestations organisées
et par les chefs religieux chiite après
les violences de samedi dernier qui ont
fait 21 morts toute la ville de machad
est en grève à téhéran il ya aussi pour
la quatrième journée consécutive une
manifestation contre le régime
des coups de feu ont été entendus ce
matin mais on ne sait pas pour l'instant
s'il ya des victimes
sur le plan politique on s'achemine vers
la formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
civil
le chat a reçu une nouvelle fois
monsieur sadi ancien premier ministre et
membre de l'opposition modérée
avant d'accepter de former un
gouvernement monsieur sadi qui
souhaitent mettre au point un certain
nombre de réformes
il voudrait surtout diminuer les
pouvoirs du shah d'iran j'ajoute que la
production pétrolière de l'iran est au
plus bas ce matin dix fois moins de
barils produits qu'en temps normal les
productions en pratiquement paralysé par
de nouvelles âmes état de siège et loi
martiale en turquie pour deux mois des
émeutes ont fait une centaine de morts
ce week-end plusieurs attentats à la
bombe ont été commis hier en quarts à un
commentaire de françois xavier dos ses
moeurs s'ajoutent aux villes que des
violences politiques ont causé cette
année en turquie
ces jours ci les émeutes les plus graves
ont eu lieu à karaman maras où on a vu
des affrontements d'une rare sauvagerie
les formations extrémistes ni avoir joué
un rôle dans cette affaire
leur action ne contribue pas moins à la
tension actuelle d'une part on trouve
l'extrême droite du colonel turc est
soutenue par de nombreux ouvriers et le
parti du salut national de monsieur
erbakan qui veut remplacer l'état laïc
par un état musulman
de l'autre on trouve des groupes
communistes hockey l'extrême droite veut
un peu trop facilement assimiler la
minorité de religion chiite contre les
deux les modérés ne savent pas trop à
quel diable se vouer monsieur demirel
chef du principal parti d'opposition a
choisi la droite quand on premier
ministre monsieur bul 1 tc vite il
s'efforce de rassurer ceux qui
l'accusent de passivité les 1 en faveur
des fascistes les autres en faveur des
communistes mais à l'étranger
la question que l'on se pose surtout
c'est de savoir si après l'iran la
turquie ne va pas connaître une crise
qui affaiblirait c'est important maillon
de l'otan
la paix au proche orient n'est plus un
problème le président égyptien anouar
el-sadate viens de le dire dans une
interview télévisée au caire les accords
de camp david ont jeté des bases solides
pour la paix qui interviendra tôt ou
tard anouar el sadate fêtait hier son
60e anniversaire dans son petit village
natal dans le delta du nil à cette
occasion monsieur ces dates a posé la
première pierre d'une cité moderne qui
accueillera 160 familles une
construction financés personnellement
par le chef de l'état égyptien grâce au
montant de son prix nobel et grâce aux
droits d'auteur du livre qu'il a écrit
où il relate l'histoire de sa vie le
proche orient ce matin c'est aussi la
tournée du ministre français des
affaires étrangères dans les pays du
golfe
première étape le koweït où monsieur
françois poncet évoquera dès ce matin
les efforts de paix au proche orient
avec la france souhaite global est aussi
la hausse du pétrole décidé par les pays
de l'opep le ministre français parlera
aussi peut-être de l'agriculture en
effet plusieurs pays arabes utilisent de
plus en plus les devises que le rapporte
le pétrole pour développer leur
agriculture c'est le cas en irak où des
milliers d'hectares de la mésopotamie
sont remis en culture pour fournir
l'alimentation de troupeaux de vaches
laitières des troupeaux installées dans
des fermes ultra moderne comme on en
voit encore très peu en france
d'ailleurs
et c'est pourtant la france qui vient
d'installer entièrement en irak l'une de
ces fermes vendus en somme clés en main
reportage jean françois robinet
le tigre l'un des deux fleuves qui
irrigue la mésopotamie il traverse la
capitale de l'irak
bagdad 2 millions d'habitants près d'un
cinquième de l'ensemble de la population
l'industrie et surtout artisanale
travail du cuivre tapie mais la grande
richesse du pays c'est bien sûr le
pétrole qui permet justement de
moderniser l'agriculture
plus de 60% des irakiens vivent des
produits du sol l'irak est le premier
producteur de dates au monde
lorsqu'il est irrigué grâce aux canaux
qui rejoignent le tigre et l'euphrate
le sol est très fertile mais pour des
raisons diverses
longtemps pays de nomades se contentant
dé lever moutons et chèvres
l'agriculture était négligée elle fait
aujourd'hui un bond considérable en
avant et en plein désert dans trois
régions du pays le gouvernement irakien
a décidé d'implanter des fermes
ultramoderne la construction de l'une
d'entre elles a été confiée à une
société française d'engineering qui
dépend du groupe national entreprises
minières et chimiques la ferme
d'al-khalis abrite déjà 1500 têtes de
bétail
ce projet parmi d'autres a pu aboutir
grâce à la forte implantation dans le
monde de la société commerciale des
potasses d'alsace filiale du groupe emc
cela en étroite collaboration avec beck
engineering
nous nous efforçons effectivement de
mettre au service de cette espèce de
grand mouvement d'expansion les pays
sous développés vers l'agriculture
nos compétences et nos moyens en même
temps que nous les valorisons d'ailleurs
il n'y a certainement pas une stagnation
de l'aviculture européenne mais il ya un
certain ralentissement de son expansion
et nous pensons que nous pouvons
valoriser nos techniques les matériels
les produits français
en amorçant de nouveaux mouvements à
l'étranger alors ceci correspond à ce
que nous avons fait en irak en
association au fond avec le gouvernement
irakien auto pour le compte du
gouvernement irakien qui nous l'avait
commandé et c'est pour nous en effet une
très importante étape il ferme clé en
main qui coûte combien
am c'est un gros investissement c'est
une ferme qui représente de l'ordre de
120 millions de francs
vous avez beaucoup d'autres projets
comme celui-ci nous avons plusieurs
projets au moyen-orient
s'appuyant en particulier sur cette
expérience qui est en situant placard de
la mésopotamie constitue évidemment un
centre d'intérêt particulier pour
l'ensemble des pays du moyen âge toutes
les installations sont ultramodernes la
ferme dans n'occupe pas moins 150
personnes et pour trois ans six experts
français qui assure la mise en route
15 cents hectares sont déjà mises en
culture pour un projet de 2000 hectares
l'irrigation réalisé par la france
permet au bout d'un an seulement
d'obtenir de bonnes récoltes de luzerne
d'orge de sorgho et de maïs
les aliments sont préparés sur place
avec les récoltes dans une véritable
usine de transformation
entièrement automatisé sol des
compléments sont fournies par la firme
française sander ce elle aussi filiale
de mc d'autres matériels viennent de
france comme les deux salles de traite
et les outils de travail du sol et de
récolte
avec la ferme la société peq engineering
à la charge de construire un village qui
doit abriter 500 personnes et comprendra
bien entendu une école
situé à proximité d'un village
traditionnel au coeur d'une palmeraie
c'est l'image de la vie moderne
le contraste entre l'agriculture d'hier
et celle de demain
il est toutefois raisonnable d'imaginer
que l'avenir sera fait d'un compromis
entre ces deux formes de vie afin d'
éviter un changement trop brutal des
coutures retour en france maintenant
avec l'actualité politique et une
interview de françois mitterrand qui
paraît aujourd'hui dans le journal la
croix
le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste fait le bilan de l'année
politique et il estime que la
législature ne devrait pas dépasser
l'élection présidentielle de 1981 je
commence peuvent à me poser la question
de savoir si elle ne s'achèvera pas
juste avant et françois mitterrand
évoque les difficultés au sein du parti
socialiste
on s'intéresse beaucoup à ma succession
et on cherche à la précipiter tout cela
se traduit forcément en conciliabule en
coalition et en intrigue auquel j'oppose
tout simplement la ligne du parti
socialiste depuis 10h ce matin toutes
les routes d'accès à longwy sont bloqués
par les sidérurgistes c'est une nouvelle
protestation contre les suppressions
d'emplois prévues dans la sidérurgie
lorraine donc blocage des routes depuis
ce matin et pendant 48 heures à partir
de mardi prochain les nouvelles mesures
concernant le financement de la sécurité
sociale seront appliquées il s'agit vous
le savez du relèvement des cotisations
pour les entreprises et pour les
salariés une sécurité sociale qui n'est
pas une invention française tous les
grands pays industrialisés dispose de
régime presque identique y compris
l'urss où il existe une sécurité sociale
pour les 270 millions d'habitants elle
est entièrement à la charge de l'état et
les soviétiques considère que c'est
l'une de leurs réussites les plus
spectaculaires regarde l enquête
réalisée en urss par françois go et par
une équipe de tf1
pour toute la population en urss les
soins médicaux sont gratuits les
médicaments aussi ou presque et le pays
compte le plus fort pourcentage de
médecins dans le monde
trente et un pour dix mille habitants
contre 16 pour 10000 aux états unis
mais qui financent la sécurité sociale
eh bien il n'y a pas de cotisations
prélevées sur les salaires
il ya simplement des cotisations versées
par les entreprises auxquelles s'ajoute
le cas échéant un complément puis sur le
budget de l'état et les fonds de la
sécurité sociale sont gérés par les
syndicats tandis que leur usage est
contrôlé par les comités syndicaux
l'entreprise à titre d'exemple sauve
dire qu'en 1967 parce que nous avons
assuré repos avec tous les soins
médicaux appropriés à 489 mille
personnes et l'année dernière
lemay aux repos étaient assurés à 767 un
stimuli travailleurs politique de la
santé axée sur la prévention
chaque année plus de 5000 établissements
de cure préventorium et maisons de repos
accueille quelque 33 millions de
soviétiques
cependant il ya le revers de la médaille
médicaments rares équipements
hospitaliers désuet hôpitaux surpeuplés
et les médecins américains qui pendant
plusieurs mois ont travaillé en urss
estime que les médecins se lier deux
pics sont moins qualifiés que leurs
collègues occidentaux médecine axée sur
le quartier où vivent les salariés et
sur l'entreprise où il travaille
pour les 450 salariés de la ferme d'état
qu'il dirige en georgie sur les bords de
la mer noire
cet homme a fait construire un présent
thorium danseurs vont avoir l'occasion
composée non seulement les réveiller
elle est personnelle et s'offre aux mais
aussi ceux qui trouveraient par exemple
médecine gratuite sans doute médecine
collective aussi en urss un même groupe
de médecins prend en charge un même
groupe de population
les policiers sont de plus en plus
persuadés qu'à l'origine de l'incendié
qui a détruit ce week end le restaurant
mais faire à nice il y à une affaire de
racket des bidons d'essence ont été
retrouvés dans les décombres
le gérant du restaurant n'est autre que
le capitaine de l'ogcnice l'équipe de
football jean marc guillou un
commentaire de maurice olivari deux
explications possibles à cet incendie
criminel qui a détruit une grande partie
du mef r2 hypothèse qui touche à la
personnalité de l'ancien propriétaire et
du nouveau gérant
l'ancien propriétaire c'est urbain
giaume condamné le 4 juillet dernier à
20 ans de prison pour trafic d'héroïne
considéré comme l'un des hommes les plus
puissants du milieu niçois géoméga sans
doute conserver des intérêts dans cette
affaire serait alors la victime
indirecte des incendiaires
c'est la thèse du règlement de comptes
version plus probable c'est du moins
celle que semble retenir les enquêteurs
le racket dans la victime serait cette
fois une autre grande figure de la côte
d'azur mais pour des raisons plus
honorable le footballeur jean marc
guillou capitaine de l'ogcnice il est
depuis 1975 cogérant de ce bar
restaurant mais certifie n'avoir jamais
été menacé par le moindre aux
raquetteurs lemay faire serait alors
l'exception qui confirme la règle car
rares sont à nice à cannes ou à
marseille
les propriétaires de bars ou de boîte de
nuit qui peuvent lire aujourd'hui
raquette connaît pas
dernier chapitre de l'actualité
l'actualité sportive une grande aventure
a commencé ce matin pour cent soixante
seize pilotes d'autos et de motos qui
ont quitté paris pour dakar 8500 km d'un
rallye qui leur fera traverser l'algérie
le mali le niger et le sénégal
cent soixante seize concurrents donc
dont la moitié en moto les deux roues
sont d'ailleurs favori avec surtout
christian de noyer champion de france de
trial du côté des voitures jacky privé
et cyril neveu ont remarquablement
préparé ce paris dakar et ils seront
sans doute bien placés en tout cas la
difficulté de cette épreuve rend tout
pronostic particulièrement hasardeuse
nous parlerons souvent de ce paris dakar
dans notre journal
car une équipe de tf1 avec jean pierre
chapel et jean-françois dunac tente
l'aventuré et nous fera vivre au fur et
à mesure le déroulement de cette course
oui beaucoup de véhicules à 4 euros mais
aussi énormément jean pierre pernaut
viens de vous le dire véhicules à deux
et on remarquera sans aucun doute que
encore une fois les japonais se taille
la part du lion dans la préparation de
cette épreuve avec les quatre grandes
marques de motos et puis aussi la
présence des allemands on oublie
quelquefois que en europe l'industrie de
la moto si elle n'existe pas en france
ou si elle a existé où elle a été
particulièrement brillante ça n'existe
pas en france existe dans d'autres pays
européens les allemands bien entendu
avec les fameuses bmw et les italiens
les italiens qui pratique la moto d'une
façon un peu différente de celle
pratiquée en france
un reportage de claude brevets
le plus surprenant sur les autoroutes
italiennes n'est pas la prolifération
des grosses cylindrées dans ce pays qui
est le second producteur de moto au
monde après le japon mais mise à part
une certaine fantaisie dans le respect
du code de la route
le fait que le casque ne soit pas encore
obligatoire il devrait l'être à partir
de l'été prochain
et encore seulement sur les routes
quant au permis moto il en coûte dès que
l'on à 16 ans l'âge minimum quelques 30
francs pour un examen portant uniquement
sur le coq
ces machines impressionnantes ici près
de côme dans le nord de l'italie à deux
pas de la suisse on en est c'est une
centaine par jour dans ses usines qui
sont à la moto ce que la rolls est à
l'automobile
tout juste sortis des chaînes de montage
elle passe une à une entre les mains de
techniciens implacable et de pilote
inconnu mais parfaitement rodé
à
cette société la plus importante
d'italie a fabriqué en 1978 quelque 115
mille machines comme on dit ici des
toute grosse au tout petit
de quoi faire rêver les amateurs le
monde entier les achète 75 pays
l équipe même de los angeles à genève en
passant par montevideo et abou dhabi les
police ou l'armée de vingt états du
globe à commencer naturellement par
l'italie
les plus grosses parts le plus loin les
états unis avant tout mais de plus en
plus les italiens réussissent à forcer
le marché japonais ce qui est une
prouesse assez exceptionnel plusieurs
centaines vendu en 1977 chez le géant
asiatique
mais avec la demande les petites
industries fabricant de petites
cylindrées tout terrain se multiplient
et sont elles aussi très compétitif
jusqu'à l'exportation notamment dans les
autres pays européens
pourtant la plupart eux mêmes
producteurs
n'empêche que ces machines frappé en
italie de près de 35 % de taxes coûte
cher
cela n'empêche pas le motocross de se
développer à travers le pays
à grande vitesse
ce que l'on appelle ici le foie rist rad
c'est à dire littéralement hors des
routes est en pleine expansion
les clubs se multiplient et ici par
exemple sur les dizaines de petites
collines qui entourent hommes le terrain
est parfait pour ce genre d'exhibition
et de plaisir pendant les week-ends on
organise même des compétitions locales
la moto phénomène retrouvait ces
dernières années est de toute évidence à
nouveau en plein essor qu'il s'agisse
des fables le monstre des routes des
moustiques de la boue ou des
motocyclettes tout propre à l'image de
leur jeune propriétaire sortant du lycée
de rome
quand on ne revient pas aux scooters de
la dolce vita
mais ça c'est une autre histoire rome
tf1 quand j'entends trop brovelli nous
parler chiffres à l'appui image de la
puye de l'industrie italienne de la moto
je regrette peut-être que l'industrie
française ne soit pas aussi dynamique et
expansionniste calais on it est salie et
bien nous allons parler maintenant de la
bourse non pas pour rejoindre françois
de nattier la bourse de paris avec les
cours tout de suite car il y a eu un
léger retard de cotation mais pour
parler avec ti vct flornoy qui est
syndic des agents de change de l'année
boursière
d'abord pourquoi ce retard de cotation
d'après vous vous n'êtes pas à la bourse
aujourd'hui vous êtes venu sur notre
plateau alors pourquoi d'après vous
peut-il y avoir 20 minutes de retard le
lendemain de noël et bien tout
simplement parce que vous le savez la
loi monnerie accorde un dégrèvement de
5000 francs aux épargnants qui
achèteront des actions offrent des
actions françaises avant la fin de
l'année il y a toujours des gens qui
attendent le dernier moment et nous
sommes depuis la semaine dernière
débordé par une foule de petits ordres
de gens qui veulent acheter leur 5030
valeurs françaises avant la fin de
l'année ils ont attendu le dernier
moment et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous enregistrons un retard dans no kata
sion aujourd'hui l'impression se
présente il va y avoir ces jours-ci de
l'embouteillage
il peut y avoir un certain embouteillage
mais nous y faisons nous y faisons face
et si nous avons dû commencer avec un
petit quart d'heure de retard nous
cotation à terme
je vous prie je prie les téléspectateurs
et les épargnants de bien vouloir nous
en excuser
alors monsieur flore on va comment va la
bourse
et bien la bourse va incontestablement
elle va mieux elle a changé de couleur
en 1978 un journal financier titrait ce
matin en se posant la question de savoir
si l'année 1978 dans les annales de la
bourse serait l'année du rattrapage ou
l'année du renouveau eh bien je crois
pour ma part que c'est à la fois l'année
du rattrapage est l'année du renouveau
du rattrapage tout d'abord parce que le
marché avait pris un retard très
important depuis 3 ans du fait de la
succession d'événements électoraux dont
l'issue ne lui était pas dont l'issue
est envisageable ne lui étaient pas
favorables c'est le moins que l'on
puisse dire il est certain que au
lendemain des élections législatives
d'un seul coup en moins de deux mois le
marché a récupéré presque 30% en hausse
rattrapant ainsi la quasi totalité de la
baisse de ces deux dernières années
mais après ces produits réellement un
phénomène de renouveau en ce sens que
les mesures de fond prises par monsieur
monnerie pour redonner la liberté aux
chefs d'entreprise pour les réinstaller
dans la concurrence pour leur faire
acquérir une certaine marge une certaine
élasticité dans leurs marges du fait de
la libération de leurs prix tout ceci a
concouru à redonner confiance à la
clientèle traditionnelle de la bourse
qui depuis un certain nombre d'années
avait tendance à penser que toutes les
sociétés marchait dans une espèce de
grisaille uniforme soudain un régime de
contrôle de prix et que de ce fait là
aucune ne pouvait prétendre un jour ou
l'autre et brillamment son épingle du
jeu
vous venez de parler de la clientèle
traditionnelle est ce que la clientèle
quand même tendance à changer
aujourd'hui en raison peut-être même de
ces de ces mesures
est-ce que vous avez des nouveautés qui
viennent vers la bourse
incontestablement la loi monory dont
nous avons
ja parlait drainent vers la bourse et
plus particulièrement par le canal des
sociétés d'investissement à capital
variable et sicav une nouvelle courte
une nouvelle couche d'épargnants qui
n'était jamais venu en bourse jusqu'à
présent mais le changement de toile de
fond ce qui me fait dire que 1978 est
véritablement l'année du renouveau tient
au changement de comportement de la
clientèle de fond du marché
c'est une clientèle de fonds qui avaient
peu ou prou abandonné ce marché depuis
15 ans pour se reporter sur d'autres
types d'investissements qui lui
paraissait plus séduisant et en raison
justement je voulais de de ce
comportement du de des pouvoirs publics
vis-à-vis des affaires de cette espèce
de généralisation de cette grisaille
dans la gestion de l'ensemble des
affaires côté qui avait été la couleur
dominante de ces quinze dernières années
et bien aujourd'hui où la couleur de la
toile de fond est nettement changé
on assiste de la part de cette clientèle
de fond du marché un changement de
comportement et peut-être est-elle en
train d'abandonner certains des autres
investissements vers lesquels elle
s'était portée pour remettre l'accent
sur l'investissement valeurs mobilières
il ya quand même chez certains
aujourd'hui un regard intéressé sur ce
qui se passait la bourse mais un regard
qui ne permet pas de tout comprendre en
définitive on a eu une éducation
boursière assez peu développée en france
en matière économique en général
je suis frappé par exemple aux états
unis par le fait que dès l'école
secondaire
les enfants savent regarder les courts
de la bofa les cours de wall street sont
intéressés même par ce qui s'y passe est
ce que vous ne voyez pas que les y
aurait il y aurait un effort à faire
je ne le crois pas j'en suis certain ça
fait déjà quelques années que nous
l'avons commencée mais vous savez faire
acquérir à une population qui
ils ignoraient tout de l'économie lui
faire acquérir progressivement une
certaine culture boursière lui faire
comprendre ce que c'est qu'une action
lui faire comprendre ce que c'est qu'une
obligation et enfin lui faire admettre
que l'action et l'obligation doivent
avoir une place dans l'investissement de
les peindre dans l'investissement du
patrimoine c'est le travail d'une
génération
ce travail est amorcé nous nous savons
que nous avons encore beaucoup à faire
pour rattraper le retard que les que
nous avions pris sur les américains dans
ce domaine bien je me disais que nous
avions un peu de retard
non pas vis américain mais vis-à-vis de
la cotation aujourd'hui où les cotations
aujourd'hui ce retard a l'air d'être
rattrapé françois de natty alors
optimisme est il bien oui tout à fait le
climat de la bourse reste orientée à
l'optimisme d'un optimisme d'ailleurs
très calme sur le marché interne
il faut dire que le retard de monsieur
flornoy viens de vous parler concerne
exclusivement les valeurs du comptant
les achats de noël sur la bourse et
achat de des retardataires ont lieu
uniquement nature mans sur le marché du
comptant le dollar est totalement
inchangé à 4 francs 26 et parmi les
valeurs qui monture marchés à terme qui
défilent maintenant devant vous on note
michelin dont le prix des pneumatiques
va augmenter de 6% à partir du mot
janvier prochain qui fut 14 points de
hausse également l'air liquide une des
valeurs les plus en vedette depuis des
mois sur le marché de perry qui monte de
3 francs et peugeot citroën remonte de 6
francs en effet le mois de novembre pour
l'industrie automobile française a été
excellent alors que l'on craignait un
petit ralentissement
même les valeurs sidérurgiques
aujourd'hui comme jr qui va bientôt
apparaître sont en hausse aujourd'hui
sur le marché de paris jean heures que
dont 450 c'est à dire 60 centimes de
hausse ce qui fait tout de même un peu
mieux 3 % tandis que les skis rossignol
monde 25 mini prix montent lui-même de 6
francs et vous voyez que le retard tout
de même explique qu'à cette heure-ci la
corbeille de sa part encore entièrement
côté parmi les valeurs qui montre le
plus il ya des banques notamment le
crédit foncier de france dont on
s'attend que le prochain emprunt qui
sera lancé au mois janvier face date
puisque il serrait et me dit on sans en
avoir confirmation au dessous de 10 %
confirmant là
à la baisse des taux d'intérêt qui est
favorable aux placements en valeurs à
revenu variable la compagnie bancaire
est une des meilleures valeurs de
l'année elle a fait une des plus fortes
hausses et la remonte aujourd'hui de 7
francs les valeurs comme say it et
alcatel ont rencontré un monde se
demande de 9 francs les presses de la
cité à 330 x mon de 850 les presses de
la cité je vous le rappelle sont parmi
les valeurs dont on espère qu'elles
seront casano font des bénéfices en
hausse sensible pour l'année du 978
quelques baisses tout de même soin qu'il
s'agit de prises de bénéfices comme sur
l'eau sein du ce une des valeurs qui a
le plus monté sont au contraire qu'il
s'agisse le phénomène probablement très
passager comme sur le grand kiff et une
baisse depuis le droit de 3% à 1902
francs les maisons phénix paire de 6
francs et la compagnie du midi qui était
également une valeur qui a beaucoup
monté d'un lieu à des prises de
bénéfices et perd aujourd'hui castres
alors c'est également à paris des achats
de noël qui interviennent c'est à dire
que le napoléon à 268 franc 90 monde de
280 et 49 1984 ans le lingot d'un kilo
monde de 115 îles valeurs étrangères
sont irrégulières les allemandes sont en
vedette aimé les valeurs américaines qui
avaient pourtant très vivement monté
vendredi dernier à wall street sont
plutôt orientés à la baisse aujourd'hui
ainsi que les mines d'or et les voleurs
belge petrofina perd 50 centimes en
valeur indexé sur l'or cela ours ou
moins pour le 7 % qui à 3789 rang de 87
ch le rouge tandis qu à 714 offrant au
contraire de 4 9% en 1973 père croit
antisida bourse avoue yves mourousi ça
voyage passionnant maintenant que je
vous propose en compagnie de jean-claude
perpère 1978 aura été l'année de
l'espoir
un espoir apparemment déçu en ce 26
décembre la paix n'est toujours pas
signée entre israël et l'egypte et on
espère quand même qu'un jour les
possibilités de conflits entre
israéliens et égyptiens et arabes seront
définitivement éliminés sur tous ces
conflits entre frères ennemis pour quoi
faire et demi bien parce que
on en est de plus en plus persuadés
juifs des arabes sont les fils d'un même
père et ont tellement de choses en
commun
les découvertes archéologiques tendent à
le prouver de plus en plus et dans cette
région du proche orient que nous allons
découvrir maintenant elle démontre et
les preuves sont là quotidienne même si
de temps en temps les uns ou les autres
ne veulent pas les reconnaître
jean-claude perpère est allé en syrie où
des archéologues viennent de découvrir
les vestiges d'un empire oublier d'une
ville perdue où les gens s'appelait déjà
ismaël prénoms arabes et israël prénom
hébreu deux mille cinq cents ans avant
j'étais à bloc d'argile ce sont des
livres écrits il y a quatre mille cinq
cents ans
leurs découvertes et leurs déchiffrement
font surgir du passé un royaume inconnu
et nous font remonter aux origines mêmes
de notre civilisation
mardi qu un petit village du nord de la
syrie près ce cadeau c'est à une sorte
de colina rasé qui se détache sur la
plaine
cette colline de 1 km de diamètre c'est
un tel un monticule artificielle formé
par une succession de ville antique
empilées les unes sur les autres
des cités aux murs de briques séchées au
soleil friable et donc régulièrement
reconstruite cours des âges jusqu'à leur
abandon ou leur destruction au final en
quelques années tels mardi que devenu
l'un des hauts lieux de l'histoire de
l'humanité dans sept buts depuis 1964
des archéologues italiens dirigée par le
professeur paolo mathier creusent des
tranchées dégage minutieusement à la
brosse et au pinceau des pans de murs
des escaliers des sols de maisons et des
restes de palais chaque fois plus ancien
au fur et à mesure qu'il s'enfonce dans
le sol
art
en 1975 ils font la découverte
archéologique la plus importante du
siècle
il met au jour les vestiges des blats
une ville vieille de 5000 ans capitale
d'un empire oublier enfouis au plus
profond de notre mémoire collective et
dont l'apogée se situe entre 2400 et
2200 50 avant jésus christ
tout le chemin siens
m
ici lorsqu'il était à l'époque un palais
les chercheurs exhume la bibliothèque
royale c'est emile tablettes d'argile
grave et de signes en forme de coin une
écriture connu l'écriture cunéiforme
inventer mille ans plus tôt par un
peuple voisin
les sumériens mais la langue transcrites
sur ses tablettes
elle est inconnue au moment de la
découverte chance inespérée certaines
d'entre elles livrent la clé de l'énigme
une centaine de ces livres d'argile sont
de véritables lexique les plus vieux
dictionnaire du monde ou des listes de
vocabulaire et blight sont traduites en
sumérien et bla entretenez des relations
avec les grandes villes de mésopotamie
ces dictionnaires était destiné à
faciliter le travail de ses
fonctionnaires et de ses comptables
depuis 1975 10% environ de ses tablettes
qui ont été déchiffrés et ce qu'elle
raconte est extraordinaire
et bla a été si bien pour l'
architecture pour les l'administration
pour la culture pour la religion une un
véritable centre de culture qu'on peut
les comparer aux grands centres
traditionnels des cultures des
mésopotamiens à l'est et de l'egypte à
l'ouest les relations diplomatiques
était fortement incroyable pour une
époque circuler et les derniers
témoignages de ses relations
diplomatiques a été trouvé pendant la
campagne de bla de l'année passée en 77
lorsque nous aurons nous avons trouvé
dans les ruines du palais de bla de
fragments de vases envoyés par des
célèbres pharaons d'égypte de l'ancien
empire l'inde et des ailes et celui qui
a bâti la deuxième grande pyramide des
pizzas se rebiffaient prennent
et bla
une cité commerçante qui exportait les
produits de l'artisanat du bois des
meubles et les tissus précieux une ville
de 20 à 30000 habitants au centre d'un
royaume qui s'étendait de la
méditerranée à l'euphrate et de
l'anatolie à damas en fait un véritable
empire pendant 150 ans sirois successifs
ont placé à la tête des sites est
soumise des sortes de préfets qui
collectait les impôts et faisait régner
la loi des blats de grandes villes
telles que marie est à cannes devait
payer tribut pour les y contraindre les
généraux et bellaïd n'hésitez pas à
lancer les expéditions à 700 et 1000 km
de leur base
mais ce qui fait surtout l'importance de
la découverte c'est la langue parlée par
les et blahic et d'où sont issus le
phénicien mais aussi les deux grandes
langues sémitiques actuelle l'arabe et
l'hébreu ici à et bla le mot roy se
disait melek
un arabe mellick en hébreu mais l'air
est le plus surprenant c'est le fait que
les habitants des blats se nommait déjà
ismaël et israël a look métal est parle
d'une ville qui s'appelait rousse à lima
sans aucun doute la plus ancienne
mention de jérusalem qui sera mille ans
plus tard conquise par les hébreux vers
2250 avant jésus-christ et bla et rasée
par ses ennemis
après quarante cinq siècles d'oubli et
trois ans seulement après sa découverte
elle est l'ange d'une autre bataille
arabes et juifs
chacun de leur côté en revendique la
filiation historique l1 et 3 to be
expekt
historiquement il doit être envisagée
qu'au troisième millénaire qui déloge
tout proche des hébreux shoot aurait
habité la syrie la palestine et la haute
mésopotamie
ap mais ce côté so it can
il faut également retenir que les
tablettes mais ben là mentionne des noms
de patriarche du livre de la genèse ou
d'autres noms hébreux abraham is le nom
abraham est très fréquent dans les
anciens documents domaine it could be to
make et jo on pourrait dire pour
présenter qu'il s'agit du grand père ou
du cousin d'abraham conclude si on ne
peut pas dire il s'agit de l'as bram de
la bible il est important de noter qu
apparaît stable à lennon d'abraham et
d'israël est où il irait avec cette
différence que dans la bible israël
désigne surtout un peu faiblard il
s'agit d'un prénom note wave est née de
l'histoire de l'ancien testament
ce n'est plus la bible c'est toujours
les tablettes les deux compères
et puis on peut considérer que la langue
de l'oeil et même la langue acadienne la
jeunesse de l'ouest ce sont les deux
originaux de la langue arabe
on croit littéraire mondiaux historique
c'est toujours c'est le commencement de
l'histoire de cette région et les noms
qui sont trouvés sont bien sûr à la
passe contre lyon par exemple
eichmann smael c'est à dire en arabe
esma lnc le dieu le dieu je l ai là là
dans notre langue propre nom et c'est
bien sûr elle qui était adorée à cette
époque que c'est pas un oui vous avez
trouvé aussi dit sereine et si oui
qu'est-ce que signifie cela est la
langue arabe
c'est abdallah c'est à dire le scandale
dans le climat politique qui règne au
proche orient le débat scientifique se
dégage difficilement des prises de
positions passionnel la direction
syrienne des antiquités en a d'ailleurs
conscience
elle vient de confier l'étude est la
traduction de ces tablettes à une
commission internationale de linguistes
seul en effet la vérité scientifique
pourra départager les fils d'abraham
qu'ils soient arabes ou hébreu et cette
vérité est d'autant plus souhaitable que
bhl a fait d'ores et déjà partie du
patrimoine culturel de l'humanité tout
entière
et bla deux mille cinq cents ans avant
jésus-christ une découverte grâce à
jean-claude perpère de ce thème
passionnant des origines va dire bien il
nous reste à vous souhaiter à toutes et
à tous et surtout à vous qui nous
regardaient ça la vraie vie un excellent
or d'après midi l écoute de tf1 rendez
vous si vous le voulez demain à 13h au
revoir